hi there my name is sarah this little
cutie is my son bennett as you can see
my son is a white male so here are some
books that i bought to help prevent him
from growing up to be
awful starting out strong we have c is
for consent um pretty self-explanatory
but it's a picture book that goes into
detail about consent with your body with
family no thanks
because i'm raising a feminist we've got
a is for awesome 23 inspirational women
finally we have except when they don't a
book about boys and girls liking
whatever they want regardless of their
gender
oh sorry i'm just i'm looking up the
number for a child protective services
this is a person who has a very clear
set of values that she wishes to impart
to her child her set of values suggest
that her son being white and male is
naturally inclined toward being a
terrible horrible person and so she must
indoctrinate him to believe that males
and females are completely fluid
categories and also that white males
naturally are going to be rapey seems
like good times over there